depuis le début de l'été on parle
beaucoup de vins potager les centaines
de cas de mystérieuses maladies
pulmonaires qui se sont déclarés aux
états unis de maladies qui seraient liés
à la cigarette électronique
on connaît peu de choses sur les risques
de vin potage mais cette activité là
elle est de plus en plus populaire chez
les chez les jeunes dans les écoles
aussi on en a fait état d' ailleurs à la
fin de la dernière année scolaire
on va en parler à notre chronique
science avec renault va nous guérir a
gagné renault bonjour bonjour sa fait
vers lui beaucoup beaucoup cette semaine
notamment le rabotage revenons tout
d'abord sur ce qu'on sait de cette
maladie pulmonaire
c'est un problème pour autour du qu'il
ya beaucoup de zones d'ombré il faut pas
qu'il y ait de grandes craintes autour
de ce problème là parce que les corps
restent relativement rares
mais ça montre à quel point on manque
d'informations importantes entourant la
cigarette électronique
donc si on vient sur le problème
lui-même depuis le mois de juin dernier
il ya eu 2 115 cas de maladies
pulmonaires ou de détresse respiratoire
sévère chez des jeunes de 16 à 38 ans à
travers 25 états américains et leur seul
point en commun c'est l utilisation de
la cigarette électronique empêcher les
personnes qui étaient révélés l'école
est plus grave
on a remarqué des dommages et de
l'inflammation hautement dans certains
cas les dommages étaient permanents donc
ils vont avoir la détresse respiratoire
pour le restant de leurs jours
probablement et certains ayant même eu
un décès jusqu'à maintenant
donc on n'a pas vu de tels cas au canada
pour l'instant mais santé canada sauver
vraiment près la situation pour éviter
que justement se retrouve avec soin
aussi est ce qu on a donc des indices
sur ce qui pourrait être responsable du
problème mais pour les experts le
problème ressemble ce qui se passe quand
on inhale des produits chimiques
toxiques mais des produits chimiques
dans les dents les cigarettes
électroniques
il y en a des centaines de versions
différentes donc savoir lequel il
responsable c'est très difficile pour
l'instant on n'a pas de suspect quoique
dans certains cas yoles et les
utilisateurs avaient utilisé leur
cigarette électronique avec du thc
mais c'est pas tout les cotes non plus
que la drogue est impliqué donc le
présentement le centre de prévention et
de contrôle des maladies américains
analysent 80 échantillons en provenance
de ces des cigarettes électroniques des
personnes qui ont été atteintes de ces
problèmes là mais en attendant les
résultats
leurs recommandations c'est de ne pas
utiliser la cigarette
avec des drogues ne pas utiliser des
produits qu'on aurait acheté dans la rue
ou des produits qu'on aurait fait soi
même à la maison
est ce que cette histoire là ça soulève
beaucoup de questions j'imagine sur
l'effet à long terme aussi du vapo temps
et ça c'est quelque chose pour lesquels
on manque beaucoup d'informations en ce
moment fait nouveau et le problème c'est
que le mythe qui entoure la cigarette
électronique c'est que c'est un produit
qui sans danger mais ça c'est pas vrai
oui c'est moins problématique que la
cigarette classique et moins c'est mieux
beaucoup moins d'agents cancérigènes par
exemple à l'intérieur mais les effets
long terme
eux ils sont inconnus lieu des études
qui ont montré par exemple que la vapeur
qu'on y aille dans la cigarette
électronique et contient des métaux
lourds donc des métaux qui viendrait de
l'élément chauffant à l'intérieur de
l'appareil
il ya d'autres études qui ont regardé la
composition du liquide qui ont marqué
que certains aient produit qu'on utilise
pour lui de donner sa consistance comme
le glycérol le propylène glycol
mais eux quand on chauffe ces produits
là et qu'on lit zinal
mais ça peut donner des molécules qui
sont toxiques puis qui peuvent
endommager les poumons créer des
problèmes cardiaques et qui peuvent même
être cancérigène mais pour le reste
mais la sig électrique monde disait elle
est un élément qui c'est un phénomène
qui est trop récent dans l'histoire dans
l'histoire humaine pour qu'on ait eu le
temps de faire les études long terme qui
sont nécessaires pour vraiment savoir si
tous ces problèmes là qu'on a remarqué
dans les petites études peuvent
entraîner entraîné problèmes de santé
long terme comme on l'a vu par exemple
dans le code la cigarette on dit renaud
que ça aide à arrêter de fumer il ya
même des médecins qui est lequel d'éclat
mais est ce que les études sont clairs à
ce sujet là les études sont très ambigu
à ce sujet là parce qu'il ya beaucoup
étonné que beaucoup de types de
cigarettes électroniques différent
beaucoup de produits mais il ya
certaines indépendamment quelques
lesquels sont observés dans les études
les effets varient certaines études
disent que side dont disent que non une
des plus importantes sur le sujet était
faite par le new england journal of
medicine et elle montre que la cigarette
cigarette électronique est deux fois
plus efficace que les patchs ou les
légumes à la nicotine par exemple pour
et d'arrêter de fumer
donc ça donc ça prête et ça pourrait
aider pour les fumeurs effectivement
mais le problème c'est que ces produits
là sont aussi très propice pour juste
pour les fumeurs sont aussi très
populaires chez les jeunes et il ya des
études parues par exemple récemment
qu'ils ont montré que au cours de la
dernière
né en 2007 et 2018 le nombre de jeunes
de 16 à 19 ans qui avaient consommé la
cigarette électronique avait doublé
passant de 1 9% la population générale
et le nombre de jeunes qui tous exposés
à la fumée secondaire qui viennent de
ces cigarettes là elle aussi est en
hausse à 33%
donc là on se rapproche des chiffres de
la cigarette classique et même si on
vend c'est la cigarette électronique
comme outil qui peut arrêter d arrêter
de fumer mais ce genre de produits ne
peut arrêter c'est ce produit peut
attirer de nouveaux fumeurs et si on
augmente le nombre de fumeurs et l'on
peut se retrouver des situations comme
les codes de maladies qu'on a eus aux
états unis en ce moment d'ailleurs c'est
devenu un fléau dans bien des écoles
secondaires en suisse à merci beaucoup
ça fait plaisir